[Music]
another boohoo party a lot to celebrate
obviously Ashley and Jared engaged how
long the airport
you know I'm their new chauffeur it's
great are you third-wheeling a little
bit tonight a little bit yeah do you
like that is it fine no they're they're
good friends yeah how long did you have
to keep it a secret
their engagement yeah he's gonna do it I
knew he's gonna do it but Oh in terms of
like him yeah just like a couple weeks
okay
what was your reaction when he told you
was there a conversation he definitely
didn't ask my advice like he knew what
he was going to do so I was just really
excited for him yeah so it was just more
of a lot of excitement and obviously you
know we just kind of talked through some
things but he definitely knew what he
was gonna do there was like it wasn't
like he was like asking me if I should
do it or anything like that he was he
was dead-set so so I was very excited
for him then yeah I just had to keep it
a secret for a couple weeks
did you help at all with the proposal
were you instrumental no I was I was all
Jared I had played no role in that and
after three years of dating and I think
he's probably been in love with her the
whole time I think he knew what you
wanted to say that's the funny thing
it's I like that you brought that up
because she was so in love with him for
so many years what clicked with him do
you think I don't know I think sometimes
you know guys are a little slow was that
fair facial reaction rates I think it's
kind of the classic case of Ashley moved
on and I think Jared realized just how
special ashley is to him and I think the
thought of not having Ashley his life
for the rest of his life is not
something he was very fond of and so it
kind of jolted him I think
have you talked wedding planning with
them at all do you know I know I'm
planning the wedding okay yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna marry them you heard it here
first I'm gonna ask if maybe you would
officiate the wedding I would I know I'm
sure they I'm sure there's a line of
people that know they haven't run
anything by me at a sense of retic
wedding planning I'll have to ask them
you're gonna have to find a date for
that wedding yeah probably
probably are you you're still single
there's pictures of you in Rumer Willis
that had people talking are you guys
just friends like one of my best friends
I love her to death but we are just
friends are we gonna see you guys on the
small screen on the big screen together
is there maybe an acting project in the
works you know that would be great
someday I think rumors at a different
level than I am right now I'm working
very hard to improve my skills but you
know we're best friends so you know and
then before I let you go of course as a
leading man of the bachelor and then we
have now Becca the Bachelorette there's
been some controversy this season how
would you what advice would you give to
her to navigate that everything with
Lincoln Garrett as far as the Lincoln
stuff I don't I I think that'll
hopefully take care of itself you know
I've only met Becca once she seems she
has a great personality she seems like a
very intelligent woman you know and so I
don't know who she ends up with but you
know people I don't know I mean it's a
tough situation but I think she'll you
know stick to her guns she's proven that
you know she has conviction and that she
is not afraid to speak her mind I think
that's a great trait of hers and I think
whatever she has happened whatever her
values are I think that she will do them
and and just stick to what's important
to her and I think it'll hopefully work
itself out but you know it's a you know
Garrett I know he had those
controversial tweets and it's sad to see
the things he liked on Instagram I
thought his message was at least as best
as it could be in terms of owning it and
taking accountability and hopefully it's
a learning process right I mean maybe
some good can come of it
if he owns his mistakes and takes it as
a way to maybe you know teach others and
not be so ignorant about certain topics
and and maybe he can become enlightened
and then you know project that on to
others so maybe it'll be a good thing in
the law thank you so much so good to see
you
[Applause]